all right
vern vern uh where'd you grow up where
you from
originally
i was i grew up in a
crown point area and
chin lee mini area and that's here in
new mexico
mexico and arizona
and you're in navajo um no
full blood tell me about your childhood
you had both your parents
growing up as a kid i had most of my
parents when i was growing up as a child
yes
how was your childhood i was like
family you were good some days and
something i don't understand
how would you describe your childhood uh
a tom sawyer guy i guess i don't know
that customer
but me i just was out to want to
[Music]
go find out i was curious i'm a curious
guy
and as i grew up having fun
playing hard and just getting away from
what was your relationship like with
your parents parents were like
uh once i walked in the room i know i
was going to be disciplined to go wash
up clean i'm going to go eat
and i remember that and
i'd fall in line and do what i got to do
actually i was a good boy good sign
alcohol came into the picture for one
for you at what age
like probably eight
to twelve came in
yeah well
the parents were the ones who were
drinking on me and i was like what the
hell is going on all this
what is this about i didn't know i had
no idea
all i know is that uh
i friends up and i look like i'm curious
and i want to know but watch myself i
i'll have to run or something i had fear
of me and that basically was a
place for me watch over my
my sisters my brother
did you finish high school no
no i didn't finish high school but i
wanted to i always wanted to and i still
want to but then i got a nicer
applicator man what the hell
i see a piece of paper form most of the
people who apply for jobs in a way
so today you're living on the street
here in gallup today i was living on the
streets you know
for that time being how long you've been
homeless uh
well well over by like 20 years 20 years
and what what is the drug you use most
is it uh alcohol
i use uh alcohol and yeah i'm alcohol
tobacco marijuana and
other drugs i just kind of put on the
side
i don't use it that much alcohol is a
big problem for a lot of american
american indians correct right do you
have a lot of
i mean a lot of people from your
community that just struggle with that
with alcoholism i believe so
you could tell and you can relate and i
said i know another that's going to i
don't know what that
is witness
have you been through rehabs and things
like that i went too many halves and i
basically got some information and
it was good and boring and bad but it
was
it was for the best i think in the long
run
what do you what are you typically
what's your go-to drink
right now would be probably just some
mickey's or
just one depending on the weather
you know if it's too hot i ain't
drinking i'm not i won't drink
uh that's it oh wait till the evening to
have a couple shots and i
i call it quick
from experience do you ever get into
like
you know i've heard about people
drinking things like
rubbing alcohol and mouthwash and
lysol perfume hairspray and gatorade
stuff like that do you ever get into any
of that stuff
some of them might just to try just to
be
part of what the healthy and i it and i
read through
the ingredients i said but look at all
the other ingredients
this is some kind of concoction yeah i
tried it
i i i've always had i was always had
that daring
real bump shoes you uh go with it
let's do it you're curious curious
i think that would be a word
do you have children i have children yes
did you were you around to raise them i
raised them so but
they were going into high school and
things went
wrong leader went
get away came in now of course i was
always the brand
i take it but if i was in the brain then
i'd take it
i healed me do you still have contact
with them yeah
i i try to keep in contact with them
as much as i can right man
something tells me that now uh
i don't know i don't want to down
nobody's day
it's all like that
but uh they live not too far from here
close to that
and the beautiful children
healthy and looking back at your life
do you have any regrets do you have any
things you wish you had done
wish you hadn't done well
if you hadn't done either that there was
nothing that's always gone
what i wanted to do and didn't become
messy relative i don't need it i don't
even want it but
i had no regrets i had a beautiful life
it was
good and bad and
vice versa how old are you today
um 58 58 58 years i was born in 1960
and 45 gold i mean
burning 60 would make you for a weekend
59
or 60. for defiance arizona's before i
was born yeah
what do you do for money now what i do
for money well
i do anything that i would try to
make honest money
and nowadays i can't even
i i don't even i don't locate or even
trying to
write up a resume or look over my
blueprint
i leave it as a i lost interest
you give enough hope i lost interest
like man i'll leave it the way i want to
live if i'm still alive on my life
but [ __ ] out if i have to excuse me but
if i have to eat other
garbage can i'll do it no
pun off me
they don't understand that they don't
what's the hardest part of your life no
probably when i was
younger when i quite understand what was
going on
you know what i mean by what's going on
is
it's me you know how come mom and dad's
going to
break apart what the what's going on did
your parents split up
they were my heroes yeah i've been doing
my
spread out
in the winter it gets very cold out here
how do you survive the cold winters
with some
extra material
and basically wool
and you'd be all right do you see people
dying in the cold uh if i did i wish to
move but tell me what's up man
get up man you know you go freeze when
we're calling for you because
someone will call them for i will or
they will but that happens quite a bit
yeah are you proud of your heritage of
being
navajo hmm i never
gave a quite deep thought about that
i don't get all
bang on that stuff
i'm gonna look at it
you know and and that kind of a form
statement i look at it as i
i'm basically just a
a native young boy to a man
still want to learn i still want to know
things
and and appreciate it when i find out
about things that are
interesting and never heard and that's
when we
if you could live live your life over
again what would you do differently
uh what would i do most differently
oh man i would like to at least
just be basic to get down to basic and
take care of everything from a to b
you know i have appointment here
i gotta go get uh mighty get it
we're gonna reapply something i will
just be more responsible be more
responsible we'll be the world yes
thank you yeah i'd like to be more
responsible
then nowadays i'm just laid back i just
gave up everything i don't even want to
hear the radio or the news or nothing
yeah just want people to leave you alone
yeah i just basically want to get away
from everybody
and i knew they had problems and i just
sit there and i listen i talked to them
and now we just get a controversy and
then
yeah and we have something in common we
all
have something that's blocking
that past door to into family
there's always got to be one block so i
say you ain't family
shut up man yeah get out of the way you
we're family you just don't know
understand it basically yeah
that's why but i have my mother she's
still alive god bless you
you see your mom still i'm ready to go
see you though i'll call it but i don't
have a phone
i have a phone but the blue has had the
phone but i have no battery
i don't have no i got to give me a
sim card i got a charger but
yeah so basically we've been
camping out for about like a while
a while over two months in a certain
area
and i move up and i find i run into some
people that i know
that are relatives i didn't even know
this is a small world
all right vern well thank you so much
for sharing your story yeah and good
luck out there
i hope you get back together with your
family i do too
i i know they're doing good and i don't
want like i said i don't want to
down them i would i'd like to say hello
i love you just want to see what's up
miss your home cooking stuff like that
that's what i like
but then again i gotta get going
what i'm searching for i don't know
something i like though something i
really enjoy and i just can't find it
here
yeah octopuses don't have a hobby
a hobby it's good to have something you
love
[Music]
all right thank you very much okay thank
you
and your everything is great thank you
you